Carnegie Mellon paired with Astrobotic
is working on the pursuit of the google
lunar xprize it's a big international
competition to land on the moon travel a
certain distance take video and certain
images and send them back door I had
signed up for the costs that Professor
Whitaker it was teaching and I didn't
really know that that was a
research-based class I didn't know much
about it except that it was associated
with the Lunar XPrize project and they
showed me the different Rovers and what
the mission was all about and I was so
excited I had to get involved somehow
and then just by sitting through the
class a project was formed so I'm
working on optical orbit determination
so what that involves when the lander is
orbiting the moon we want to figure out
what that orbit is and where we are in
that orbit so we want to do this just
based on imagery on pictures taken from
a camera on the lander the big goal is
to have the entire mission be optically
based so just be able to determine where
you are from launch to landing just
based on imagery from cameras so that's
the big goal and I'm going to continue
that and hopefully see it flying 2014
this is an idea that could revolutionize
the way that planetary missions occur
the idea of cameras only
registration guidance right down to a
landing on a planet working with corrine
in this research has been an absolute
delight so the great thing about red is
that he manages to get you to keep you
on topic and guide you through what you
need to do without necessarily giving
you all the answers which is exactly
what a learning process is right but
he's also extremely approachable the
experience of seeing a project from
start to finish is something I don't
think many students actually get to do
last semester I was mostly focusing on
lunar orbits and this semester I've been
focusing on trajectories that take you
from the orbit around Earth to an orbit
around the moon so that we call that
cruise stage that in between I will be
presenting for both the lunar orbital
stage and for cruise stage I'm able to
figure out given a latitude and
longitude estimate at a specific time
figure out where you are in the lunar
orbital stage with only five kilometers
of error which is very very exciting in
terms of preparation I've been meeting
with my mentors every week I've been
giving kind of many presentations around
campus I find the best way to prepare
for any sort of presentation is to take
your slides and try to explain the whole
project to somebody who is completely
out of the field
so for something I'm meeting of minds
was actually exciting and much less
intimidating than I had originally
thought I took all of those slide
presentations that I've used in the past
added in my new results kind of put it
into context a little bit more it
provided me the opportunity to share my
research is really exciting